استشهاد اذا الصحفي حمزه نجل الزميل وائل
الدحدوح في قصف اسرائيلي استهدف صحفيين
غرب خان يونس جنوبيه قطاع
غزه اذا نعيد ما جاء في هذا الخبر العاجل
استشهاد الصحفي حمزه نجل الزميل وائل
الدحدوح في قصف اسرائيلي استهدف صحفيين
غرب خان يونس جنوبيه قطاع غزه في هذه
اللحظات كما تحدثت اذا جريمه اخرى تضاف
الى سجل قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ويضرب
اذا منزل عائله مراسلنا في غزه والى
الدحدوح حيث استشهد اذا قبل اسابيع ايضا
كما نعلم عدد من افراد عائلته بمن فيه
زوجته وابنه وايضا ابنته في عدوان
اسرائيلي استهدف منزل اذا نزحوا اليه كما
نعلم في مخيم النصيرات وسط
قطاع غزه للمزيد اذا حول هذه التطورات
معنا وليد العمري وليد رحب بك اذا ما
المعلومات المتوفره
لديك انا لله وانا اليه
راجعون استشهاد حمزه نجل زميلنا العزيز
وائل
الدحدوح قبل دقائق في قصف اسرائيلي استهدف
مجموعه من الصحفيين في منطقه غربي مدينه
خانيونس قريبه من منطقه المواصي المعلومات
التي وصلت ان قصفا اسرائيليا استهدفهم
واستشهد حمزه واخرون والزميل حمزه كان
يعمل ايضا ضمن طاقم الجزيره وكان ضمن
مجموعه من الصحفيين في تلك المنطقه التي
لجا اليها العديد من المواطنين
الفلسطينيين الذين هجروا من منازلهم وقصفت
منازلهم على نطاق واسع نعزي انفسنا ونعزي
زميلنا وائل بهذا المصاب الجلل ولا يسعنا
الا ان نقول والذين اذا اصابتهم مصيبه
قالوا انا لله وانا اليه راجعون وائل
الدحدوح كان قد نكب ايضا عندما
استهدفت جيش الاحتلال عائلته في منطقه
الصيرات مخيم انسرات في الشهر الاول من
الحرب المتواصله على غزه وكانوا قد لجوا
من منزلهم في حي الزيتون الى اقربائهم في
مخيم انسرات في الناحيه الجنوبيه من قطاع
غز
بعد ان كان الجيش الاسرائيلي قد طالب
مواطني وسكان شمالي قطاع غزه بالرحيل الى
تلك المناطق على اساس انها امنه لكنهم
قصفوا مع اقربائهم وان ذلك استشهد اثني عش
من اقربائهم وعائلاتهم بينهم كانت زوجه
زميلنا العزيز وائل الدحدوح وايضا اثنين
من اطفاله وحفيده وتواصل ذلك ايضا
باستهداف منزله في في حي الزيتون
بقصف مدمر قضى على المنطقه التي تعيش بها
العائله بالكامل بما فيها المنزل والان
يستهدفون مجموعه من الصحفيين في منطقه
قريبا من منطقه المواصي غربي منطقه
خانيونس ويستشهد حمزه وهو شاب يافع في
العشرين من عمره وهو بكر
زميلنا هو بكر زميلنا وائل الدحدوح هذه
هذا المصاب
يضاف الى مسلسل الجرائم التي
استهدفت مجموعات كبيره من الصحفيين
الفلسطينيين نحن نتحدث عن نحو
100 اكثر نحو
100 سبعه صحفيين او اكثر استشهدوا حتى
الان من بينهم نحو 60 صحفيا استهدفت ايضا
عائلاتهم ونذكر في هذا المقام وهذا الوقت
ايضا بهذا المقام الجلل بان زميلنا مؤمن
اشرافي كانت قد استهدفت عائلته واستشهد 22
منها بينهم والديه واشقائه وشقيقاته
واطفالهم وزميلنا محمد ابو القمصان ايضا
التي استهدف منزل عائلتهم واستشهد منهم
نحو 18 وانس الشريف الذي استشهد والده في
قصف استهدف ايضا منزلهم وهناك العديد من
الصحفيين وواضح بان استهداف ان الصحفيين
مستهدفين في قطاع غزه على نطاق واسع حمزه
نجل زميلنا وائل الدحدوح هو في ال9 من
عمره وهذه المره استهدف مع مجموعه من
الصحفيين كانوا يقومون بعمليات
تصوير من داخل سياره في منطقه قريبه من
المناطق التي لجا اليها المواطنون
الفلسطينيون منطقه المواصي الممتده غربي
منطقه خان يونس
وتقع على مقربه ايضا من المناطق الوسطى في
قطاع غزه هذا المصاب
الجلل يسجل ويوثق جريمه جديده من جرائم
الجيش الاسرائيلي في هذه الحرب التي تطال
المدنيين وتستهدف الصحفيين كذلك تستهدف
نحو 300 من العاملين في القطاع الطبي
والصحي في قطاع غزه استشهدوا خلالها وهناك
العديد من العاملين في الجامعات واصحاب
المحل والبيوت والعائلات الحديث الان يدور
عن ان هناك نحو 30 ال
من الذين استشهدوا
وال وايضا المفقودين في قطاع غزه وهذا
العدد مرشح ان يتزايد في ظل استمرار هذه
الحرب التي تستهدف الجميع وتستهدف الان
منذ فتره طويله بطبيعه الحال تستهدف
المناطق التي قال الجيش الاسرائيلي للناس
الجاوا اليها على اساس انها امنه